is there a point in your life and when
was it where you just were like
hey man i'm just gonna do what i do i'm
gonna do what i do i'm gonna get things
made cause i love movies i'm gonna get
people people will like them or they
won't i
can't i can't be happy or unhappy based
on
an outcome of uh the box office it's a
great question and and to throw out the
disclaimer before i head into it one
night
these are first world problems
kids
like when when you've gotten to a place
that you're trying to get to
um that's everything and you never have
any right to
that being said maintaining that is far
more difficult nobody tells you that
when you start out
you know because you're so full piss of
vinegar you're like i just want to
express myself
i'll be a director i won't be an actor
or whatever
nobody tells you like if you're lucky
enough
to get picked where they put your
you know in front of the public
then you gotta do it again then you
gotta do it again
then you gotta do it again you gotta
keep doing it until you drop
dead
and you know oh or you you get kicked
out the club
so it's like anyone comes up with a
magic trick
is an amazing thing you know sleight of
hand and like you know
like jimmy at a party i'm
like what's that and they pull the
porter out from here
clerks is me pulling a quarter out from
behind somebody's here they're like oh
that's clever well done
and i thought that would have been it
like once i made one of those then you
know
hey there's my magic trick but then you
know they're like all right what's next
and for the
last 26 years they've been going like
what's next so if i want to stay in the
game
you got to keep making you got to
maintain you've got to have longevity
and that's the thing nobody prepares you
for nobody tells you like hey man
how long do you want to be in this
you know i wish my was like
a tv season
where i broke it up into seasons where
i'm like you know after 10 seasons i'm
out or something like that
but with no defined
exit point because i don't even have a
defined exit point based on whether the
movies did good or bad because at the
end of the day i could just shoot
a lower budget movie you know like as
was the case with chase amy moratz came
out
didn't do well cost 5 million and make
them do well we went and made chase
gaming for 250 grand
that went on to make like 12 million
the